and Gil Wiesenthal co-host of what you  missed today's chart shows that  everybody is feeling good about housing  there's lots of different data points  here but they're all going in the right  direction this white line is from last  week it's the number of people who say  that now is a good time to invest in  real estate that's up at a several-year  high today this yellow line this is home  builder sentiment this is that's in a  10-year high remember how bad the home  builders got slammed that's on a really  nice run and this green chart is home  depot this is absolutely on the tears of  people who are selling building supplies  housing supplies renovation stuff  absolutely going gangbusters so pretty  much any way you slice it people are  just feeling good about housing again  its back and I'm Johanna thought that's  my killer shark locked what do you miss  at 4pm user